恐らく　ハサミ史上最凶に危ない必殺技
※良い子は真似しないでね＾＾
ｳﾞｳﾞ
SE『ﾋﾟﾆｮ×２』
（指パッチン）こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです。
SE『ﾌﾌｯ』
SE『ﾌｫｯ』
SE『ﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃ』
SE『ﾌｯ』
SE『ﾄﾞﾄﾞﾝ！』
（あの頃は）ハッ！
SE『ｶｰ』
自分でもね感心するくらい
部屋が汚いですよ
見て下さい。
（１カメ）この撮影部屋
（２カメ）編集部屋
（３カメ）玄関
（４カメ）遊び場
yeeeeeahwwwww　FOOOwww
もうホントにありとあらゆる部屋が
もう今　めちゃくちゃ汚い..ですよ
笑えないレベルでね　ホントに笑えないのと
何故そうなるかっていうと
なんか動画で使ったものとかもね
（スーパー言い訳タイム）
やっぱ捨てないとダメなんですよ　結局はね
結局なんか動画でさ　なんかいろいろと使ったものとか
なんかそれを開封する時に出ちゃう
なんか箱のゴミとかめちゃくちゃ多すぎて
なかなか捨てられなくて
そんな部屋をもう本気で掃除しようということで
もうガチで今回は掃除します。
もう断捨離ですよ
今日はもう部屋のあ◯＄☓※▽ものを
（ごまかしはじめん）
全て捨てます。　マジで
ホントに捨てる　マジデスマス協和（？）
というわけで今回の動画は
果たして
僕の家のいまあるものを全部なるべくゴミに出すと
どれくらいゴミが出るのかっていうのを
ちょっと今回検証してみようと思います
多分ビビるからね！
一人暮らしの人間の部屋じゃない
レベルのゴミが出ると思うので
今日も１日...
頑張っか！
（指パッチン）じゃあ掃除行ってきます。
SE『ﾄﾞﾄﾞﾝ！』
業者さん「ﾏｲﾘﾏｽ」
は「妻と（？）机がここ」
業者さん「ｺﾚﾃﾞｽﾈ」
は「はい」
業者さん「妻りますね（？）」
は「あ、行けますか！」
SE『ﾎﾟﾝｯ』　は「じゃあそれでお願いします」
業者さん「ﾜｶﾘﾏｼﾀ」
業者さん「布団...」
もう一人のはじめ「やべぇノリで言っちゃったけど」
もう一人のはじめ「俺今日寝る場所無くなっちゃった」
～ゴミの舞～
チ◯ポジ
腕回し×２
チ◯ポジ×２
腕回し×１
パンッ
（１カメ）　Combo　1
（２カメ）　Combo　2
（３カメ）　Combo　3
（４カメ）　Combo　4
（５カメ）　Combo　5
（～心地良いピアノ～）
（急いで階段を駆け下りるはじめん）
（謎の音）
（～心地良いピアノ～）
うわっ　これヤバくない？　どうすんのこれ
うわぁ...
今回のビフォーアフターについて
（～心地良いピアノ～）
匠は...   こう語る...
匠「まあ、今回　僕が」
（～心地良いピアノ～）
匠「まあ手がけさせていただいたんですけども」
匠「まあ、ゴミ捨てただけです。」
なんということでしょう
（～心地良いピアノ～）
あの、ゴミ屑のようだった家は
一瞬で新居のように早変わり
（～心地良いピアノ～）
足の置き場もなかった　腐った玄関も
透き通ったような透明感を取り戻し
（～心地良いピアノ～）
遊び場だった部屋にも
活気が戻りました
（～心地良いピアノ～）
（ドゥテルテ×４）
（ドゥテルテ×２）　トゥー　トゥルル
（ドゥテルテ×２）　トゥートゥー　トゥルル
（ドゥテルテ×２） トゥー　トゥルル
（ドゥテルテ×２）　トゥー　トゥールル
トゥルル　ルールー
ズタ　ズタ　ズタ　ズタ
ず・た・た・たん♪
業者さん「ｶﾞﾝﾊﾞｯﾃｸﾀﾞｻｲ」
は＆業者さん「ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ」
は「ありがとうございます」
業者さん「ｳﾍﾍｗｗ」
は「ありがとうございました（一礼）」
トラック「(((((((((((っ･ω･)っ ﾌﾞｰﾝ」
まあなんだか僕ん家のゴミ屋敷がひとまず
普通の家っぽくなったな
って思いました
みんな！　掃除はちゃんとするんだぞ
じゃあな